hello and welcome back to the graveyard
of broken dreams i am once again
reviving this
second channel this time to do a book
review of
starlight by hannah lee kidder if you
don't know her she is an author foremost
and this book is kind of supernatural a
little bit horror
all very quite grounded still but she is
also
a youtuber like me and i've linked her
main channel down below
she gives some really great writing
advice she's also
really really funny which is how i first
came across her
we connected a while back and she sent
me a review copy of her book
that is out now i believe again linked
down below
uh if you want to check it out it's her
short story collection
and uh i want to talk about my feelings
on it about what i liked and
and all that sort of stuff um i've never
done this before i
am not a book reviewer but i kind of
want to do a little bit more of it and i
thought this was a really cool place
uh to start so i want to say first and
foremost that i am not a short story
writer that is
not where my skills lie and um i have
been
really trying to read a lot more of it
i've been reading te chang's exhalation
and jeff vandermeer's dead astronauts as
well as some more magical realism stuff
uh more grounded stuff because these are
sci-fi uh amy bender's
the girl with the flammable skirt and i
actually also read henley kitty's little
birds which is her first uh
set of short stories recently so i have
been trying to get a lot more into short
stories
and boy i am really glad that i did so
with that with that caveat that i'm not
you know a short story writer i really
want to say
that it's great it's
a really beautiful collection of short
stories
and they are written really really well
i particularly enjoyed one story called
contained
which was only like a page and a half
but it's uh clearly someone looking
into a vent and thinking that
something's in the vent and if they stop
looking at the vent
that the thing's gonna come out and it's
written in a way that you you're not
quite sure if it's actually there or if
it
or if it isn't there um but
uh the short stories range from like 20
pages to
just one page and for me i
really enjoyed the shorter ones uh the
the most like the ones which are just
kind of a snapshot
they were just a moment in what could be
a broader story
uh henley cutter clearly has a really
good grasp of
uh just kind of prose and metaphors
and you know just beautiful poetic
language i've actually got a couple of
lines that i want to i want to share
with you
so these are just ones that you know may
not be the best lines in the entire book
but there are ones that are kind of like
oh
oh i feel that you know i get that uh
so the first one is the house is
brittled
slouching with age and neglect and spite
and i was just like oh i can i can see
that you know i can see that house there
with that
there's another one which is uh a child
was raised on stories of crows
dark creatures with black intentions
that's from one called mother which was
another kind of shorter one
where you know you find out whether the
crows are bad
she writes really beautifully
and i want to say that that the strength
of starlight was definitely in the
atmosphere
in the feeling in the kind of
somber sorrowful but sometimes hopeful
uh kind of grim but still very
grounded world that she she built
throughout all of these stories they all
had a very distinct
feeling to them there was a lot of
atmosphere and mood
those were really where the the book
shone
um for me as i said you know i preferred
some of the
the shorter ones i think that uh the
longer ones if i were to offer
you know a critique here is that coming
from someone who mostly reads
longer novels uh you know the build-up
of tension
to kind of climaxes and whatever it's
very much about
is very much a part of how i process
fiction and
the stories that sort of did that a bit
more the ones that had
that build up um i felt
you know were not as good as as the ones
which were very much about that mood and
feeling and atmosphere and poetic
uh poetic language the short stories i
don't think were necessarily
about that kind of you know building
attention building of tension
so much and that you know beginning
middle end leading up to a climax
i i i don't think that that's
necessarily what
you know hannah was trying to capture
here
and what she was trying to capture
you know that feeling uh was
was really well done i will say that uh
of the longer ones there's actually one
right at the very end
called passing ghosts and this was a
longer one not
the longest but it was definitely one of
the longer stories and
i really loved it it was probably one of
my favorites in
in in the book it's basically you you
you see the story of a girl who became a
ghost and is watching this
guy throughout his his life um
and again there's it's this one in
particular you know like even though
it's a longer story there wasn't really
like a build up to a climax and i think
that worked to
her advantage in this story because it
was very much still kind of just about
that
unfolding of that kind of moment of that
perspective of that
inside that person's head um
and the feeling and and tone and of of
the story that she's trying
to tell she really got into that quite
deeply
and i really liked that uh she really
pulled it off
uh throughout the entire book as well i
i want to kind of talk about things that
sort of
bring all these stories together there
are really strong
themes of kind of female empowerment or
at least
a female experience um i'm not sure
off the top of my head if there was a if
there was a single story
that wasn't from a female perspective at
least there were male characters
um some sympathetic as well but they
were they were primarily written from
from female
perspectives and that was a really
strong undercurrent of what
these short stories were about um
female experience and in terms of
getting into kind of
a mindset that obviously i am not you
know a part of i felt that was really
informative i felt that was really well
done
um it was really interesting for me to
read it from
that perspective so
yeah do i do i recommend you go and read
these yeah i
i absolutely do i really really enjoyed
it
and i hope i can see more of this kind
of writing i'm
trying to get more into short stories
and this was a great way for me to
you know part of my introduction into
that as i said links are all down below
to a youtube channel
to her book and she pulled me from one
story
to the next as i was doing it and it
only took me you know
maybe a couple of hours to get through
the entire book i don't know how long it
took me
it's not super long and it's got a
really good variety
of uh of little stories that you can you
can pull from
thank you very much you know for
watching i'm gonna try and do more book
reviews
if there is a book you'd like me to
review um
then you know let me know down below
also if you're wondering where i am and
why i'm not at my office it's because
i didn't want to clean my office and my
desk is a mess right now
uh so i decided to
set up some of my art that i have this
one is by zandrat
um she's one of my favorite artists this
one is by i can't remember but it's a
character from life is strange called
max
and this one you might recognize is
azula and zuko's
last agony kai so yeah
this is where i am just sit up in front
of my couch and decide to talk about
this but this is no setup i think this
is a good setup anyways
stay nerdy and i'll see you in the
future